dunkle materie im kosmischen netz unser
universum ein nervensystem jetzt bei
klick zum zweiten blick schon physiker
sind davon überzeugt dass das universum
fast ausschließlich aus dunkler materie
und dunkle energie besteht die uns
bekannte materie also atome machen
demzufolge nur etwa 4,6 prozent der
gesamten masse des universums aus aber
ein sicherer nachweis für die
rätselhaften dunklen materie form der
konnte bisher nicht erbracht werden
immer wieder gibt es in die filme
gravitationslinsen aber mehr eben auch
nicht aussagen der forscher zufolge
sollen diese partikel mit der masse von
etwa 2 goldatome im inneren der sonne
entstehen von dort aus sollen in alle
richtungen in den weltraum fliegen bis
dato sagte man auch dass sich die
partikel relativ dicht verteilen neuen
analysen zur folge scheint letzteres
aber nicht mehr zustimmen wie forscher
bei der datenanalyse des career service
kurz kef stellten scheinen sich die dark
matter partikel sehr viel die füße zu
verbreiten zitat das neueste ergebnis
zeigt dass die dunkle materie im
kosmischen netz die etwa ein viertel des
universums ausmacht gleichmäßiger
verteilt ist als wir zuvor geglaubt
haben erklärte martin viola von der
sternwarte leiden in den niederlanden
der kosmische netze ist ein netzwerk
ironie vierter gasnebel aber nebel auf
gas molekülen den ein oder mehrere
elektroden fehlen
wir sind positiv geladen diese die
nervenbahnen anmutenden sogenannten
filamente wurden übrigen 2014 erstmals
durch einen riesigen lichtblitz einer
galaxie wiesbaden flocken die galaxien
bilden dabei übrigens die knotenpunkte
dieses nervensystem
ich finde das schon beeindruckend unsere
unser universum ein nervensystem
funktioniert es vielleicht auch wie
einst zumindest sieht es so aus was hat
das aber jetzt bedeuten was bringt es
der wissenschaft zu wissen dass sich
unsichtbares nicht zu dicht wie erwartet
verteilt in der pressemitteilung des
european southern observatory eso heiße
zitat das überraschende
forschungsergebnis
hat auch auswirkungen auf unser
allgemeines verständnis vom universum
und wie sich in seiner 14 milliarden
jahre währenden geschichte entwickelt
hat ein deutsch auf die kundiger
widerspruch für den neuesten plank
ergebnissen bedeutet dass astronomen die
möglicherweise ihr verständnis von
einigen grundlegenden aspekten der
entwicklung des universums neu
überdenken müssen
zitat ende stehen wir also wieder man
ganz am anfang eine forschungsrichtung
naja nicht ganz
mit dem neuen ergebnissen könne man
entscheidend dazu beitragen die
theoretischen modelle der entwicklung
des universums weiterzuentwickeln so
sieht es zumindest hendrik hildebrandt
vom argelander institut für astronomie
über was man hier könnte unser universum
wie ein nervensystem funktionieren ist
es ein riesiges gehirn und alles ist
irgendwie miteinander verbunden und das
wären wir dann also die menschen
ich finde das schon ziemlich verrückt
ich bin auf eure einschätzungen gespannt
und wenn euch das video gefallen hat
lasst uns gerne genauso was einen daumen
nach oben und ein nicht vergessen
kostenlos aber dafür einfach anklicken
und ansonsten bis dann klettern